105 years ago tonight's the Titanic
struck an iceberg in the Atlantic on its
maiden voyage the so called unsinkable
ship descended hours later to the bottom
of the ocean more than 1,500 people died
it took scientists more than 70 years to
find the wreckage chip Reid shows us how
explorers are now preparing to return
for the first time in more than a decade
before the wreck disappears forever
Titanic was called the ship of Dreams
until a nautical nightmare turned it
into a legend a fateful voyage that
fascinated the public inspiring more
than a dozen films and a new generation
of explorers like Stockton Rush more
people have been to space than have been
to see the Titanic the wreck was
discovered in 1985 since then fewer than
200 people have crossed over its bow or
glided past its promenade decks rush
founder of private submersible company
ocean gate plans to increase that number
starting in may 2000 18 rush will begin
a series of yearly expeditions to the
Titanic
the first time anyone will have been to
the site in more than a decade where is
your excitement factor on this definite
level the five-person submersible that
will be used is still under construction
at a New Jersey Factory when complete
the Cyclops 2 will look like this model
and be able to dive 13,000 feet how
people will in turn exit through the
Dell it'll be one of just five
submersibles on the planet capable of
reaching the Titanic and the only one
that's privately owned one of the goals
is to generate a 3d model of the wreck a
UNESCO underwater heritage site before
it's too late
I've heard some researchers say that the
Titanic will melt away and be gone in 20
years to make the most of the
expedition's ocean gate will include
researchers and explorers for a fee but
the seats on the sub don't come cheap
they're gonna pay one hundred and five
thousand one hundred and twenty nine
because that is inflation adjusted price
of a first-class ticket on the Titanic
in 1912 even so all 54 seats for the
2018 trips have already sold out
Renate Rojas a banker by trade and
Explorer at heart paid for one of those
seats ever seen the same product job I
mean saving to go to Titanic as for the
moment when she first sets eyes on it
I'll probably cry the entire time I get
emotional about the Titanic you really
do you do Rojas isn't afraid to go more
than two miles below the waves and rush
says that's with good reason you believe
the Cyclops too is pretty much
invulnerable by the time we're done
testing it I believe it's pretty much
invulnerable and that's pretty much what
they said about the Titanic that's right
and I will go on all the all the first
dives and probably every third died so
put my money where my mouth is for CBS
this morning
chip Reid New York if I had a hundred
and five thousand loose change
ticket to our imagination for a century
you know in that really Charlie Rose not
being 100 go on that roller coaster